[Musique]
embauché comme tout le monde c'est bien
ça bien scandaleux d'ailleurs on est
serrés comme des sardines nadin co2 de
plus les wagons de voyageurs sur des
wagons à bestiaux vous prenez le métro
le matin par exemple vous voyez des
femmes avec des gosses en et métro on
est absolument bousculer serré elle
s'est obligé d'emmener leurs gosses dans
une crèche par exemple l'eau c'est
absolument scandaleux qu'on fasse
voyager les gens dans des conditions
pareilles et pour le prix qu'on veuille
parce que les transports en commun ne
font d'augmenter il s'améliore
absolument paris ça c'est ce qu'on a dit
ça
[Musique]